on this episode of the boys
for everyone what does he see
he says his name is jamie jamie don't
[__] with it just leave him alone are
those hands registered weapons yet
homelander has bravely come forward as a
whistleblower and provided evidence of
crimes committed within bought by ceo
stan edgar how could she do this to me
well i haven't seen that many sex toys
since my ex told me i was unable to
please her please take me back stephanie
well episode four is here with more
hamster attacks idiot brains and
delicious taco bowls seriously we have
the best taco bowls best taco balls are
made in trump tower grill i love
hispanics yeah i don't really speak
spanish sir
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into episode 4 theories for the
rest of the season and some of those
details you might have missed so laser
focus on that like and subscribe button
because things are about to get freaky
the beginning of the episode starts with
real life tv show solid gold which aired
from 1980 to 1988. we know that soldier
boy heroically gave his life to prevent
a nuclear meltdown in 1984 or so the
lame stream media will tell you so this
cut of soldier boy singing blondie's
rapture happened sometime between 1981
the year the single was released in
1984.
fun fact waylon flowers here was the
inspiration for the simpsons character
waylon smithers come on homer i'm
insisting on a fisting what's this about
a fisting of note is a flashback
mother's milk has with his father and
grandfather remember that he blames
soldier boy for the death of his family
the details here are a bit unclear we
know his father died at the age of 55
trying to fight vaught through the legal
system but little is known about his
grandfather and extended family the
sound of a car crash with this little
toy car here suggests soldier boy may
have been involved in some sort of car
crash killing mm's family from the
unedited soldier boy psa released on
twitter a few days ago we know that
soldier boy was a heavy drug user
if taking drugs is uncool i'm the most
uncool [__] on the planet
[__] you maybe he was under the
influence and gone into a crash with
mother's milk's family the pain of
losing his family is something mother's
milk can't seem to let go his wife even
tells him in episode one you gotta move
on marvin this is at the core of his
character arc now maybe i'm a bit dumb
but the golden black eagle emblem on
this car looks a bit similar to the one
found on the private jet the boys take
to get to russia thought i'd point it
out but it's probably nothing butcher is
busy doing what i used to do when i
worked at a theme park cleaning up
leftover blm blts this is aftermath from
his first dose of temp v that doesn't
seem to be the only side effect as
butcher's i don't give a [__] attitude
to ryan and later with kimiko suggests
like roid rage temp v may make one prone
to anger disappointed
i'm curious to see how huey's taking of
temp v will later affect his
relationship with starlight with
america's most trusted news anchor
cameron coleman homelander makes the
case that there is a hidden cabal of
powerful puppet masters pulling the
strings trying to silence him they
mentioned the new york times which in
real life wrote a piece criticizing q
anon a popular pro-trump conspiracy
theory which claims a shadowy cabal of
cannibalistic democratic pedophiles want
to bring trump down in episode 2 of this
season we learned that everyone's
favorite los poyos hermanos owner stan
edgar was none other than congresswoman
victoria newman's adopted father he's
come with a request that his daughter as
acting head of the federal bureau of
superhuman affairs punish homelander for
his outburst on live tv homelander has
started to test his boundaries and thus
must be put in his place but victoria is
hesitant if she comes for homelander it
puts the life of her daughter zoe in
danger and that's what we learn most
motivates victoria she'll do anything to
keep her daughter safe even backstab her
own father by making a deal with
homelander butcher and frenchie give a
little visit to little nina who has dirt
on two officials in the kremlin in
exchange for cash butcher wants the
whereabouts of soldier boy or at least
this weapon known as bcl red a weapon
that could potentially kill homelander
judging by the end of this episode that
weapon might be soldier boy himself more
on that in a bit so nina isn't going to
give any info over that easily she wants
sherry french's friend and former lover
but because the boys aren't willing to
give her over they have to take on a
special mission one involving kimiko
going undercover as a prostitute to
assassinate someone known as the
oligarch poor huey has to watch the
latest cut of american hero in which
homelander revealed he and starlight are
dating if you check out the vaught
international youtube channel you can
see a behind-the-scenes tour of the
american hero set and some fun little
easter eggs like this eliminated
contestant nubia who you may remember
from the diabolical animated series what
i like about this scene is how
understanding huey is after all it was
him who told starlight they need to do
whatever it takes to bring down
homelander but there's a great line of
foreshadowing here let me save you for
once with huey gaining powers at the end
of the episode i wonder if it'll be huge
who sacrifices himself to save starlight
when and if this big showdown with
homelander occurs with homelander
creepily having a key to starlight's
apartment starlight says that if
homelander touches huey she'll walk and
take her approval point somewhere else
this will end up being a hollow threat
considering homelanders coup d'etat
against stan edgar further along in the
episode a train does his best kendall
jenner impression with his turbo rush
energy drink a common theme throughout
the boys has been the commodification of
social justice issues a company like
vaught doesn't give a [__] about the
actual issues all they care about are
ratings and that sweet sweet profit i
think vaught has a responsibility here
right wait you're serious hughie calls
his boss victoria newman explaining how
he broke his arm and can't come into
work love the homelander cast signing a
constant reminder of his omni presence
even in russia the graffiti of
homelander in the soups seems everywhere
kimiko broke huey's arm as an excuse to
buy some time so that he could travel to
russia in search of this homelander
killing superweapon and he can't tell
victoria the truth because he found out
that she's that head popping soup whose
father is stan edgar back in the u.s
queen made trains which starlight finds
unusual she heard from the media that
maeve stopped training
people think what i want them to mabe
wants to give off this appearance that
she's maybe out of shape but the secret
training is all in preparation for an
eventual showdown with homelander if she
can buy butcher just one second to get a
clear shot at homelander maybe it'll all
be worth it this is all part of a maeve
redemption arc she thinks she quote has
it coming for her involvement with the
flight 37 crash its cover-up and also
her love affair with homelander when
kimiko is told by butcher she'll need to
kill in order for them to get soldier
boy's location it doesn't go over well
i'm not your [__] gun she's been
someone's puppet her entire life from
the shining light liberation army which
kidnapped her and her brother and now to
butcher and little nina in episode 1 we
saw her sing dream a little dream of me
a metaphor for her dream of a life where
she reclaims her voice both literally
and figuratively and like i predicted in
my episode 1-3 video she does lose her
power now don't fret i don't think
kimiko is gone we do see her in the
season trailer dancing in a hospital
with frenchie which might actually be
the musical episode this season
allegedly has starlight divulges the big
plan to kill homelander to childhood
flame supersonic and i love how she puts
on one of his boy band songs so that
homelander doesn't overhear them
speaking of super sonic homelander
orders some delicious taco bowls because
super sonic is hispanic this is moon
delicioso and this has gotta be a
welcome change for the deep considering
his meal last episode there is a lot
going on the scene from black noir
drawing buster beaver a chuck e cheese
type character who has ads on the vot
news network to the deep's wife
cassandra texting him on what to say and
do during the meeting poor the deep has
essentially substituted the church of
the collective which told him what to do
with cassandra in fact in the audible
exclusive deeper and deeper the deep
refers to cassandra as a siren which in
mythology lured sailors to their deaths
we're not quite sure what her motives
are just yet but she definitely wants
the deep to side with homelander she's
the one who doesn't want a train going
after blue hawk but this might have more
to do with her wanting the deep to
rebuild his connection with homelander
than anything else i mean there's no
stronger ally than homelander another
fun fact from the podcast cassandra is
on some sort of hormones i mean that
many hormones is never a good thing
trust me cassandra just turned the
corner on her whole
we don't
we did see them making love a few
episodes ago so who knows what weird
type of fish baby they'll have this
little battle between a train and the
deep turns physical in the hallway both
men are kinda at a stalemate since both
have incriminating evidence that if
turned into homelander would surely see
them lasered in two it was the deep who
retrieved the flight 37 video from the
ocean and gave it to maeve well it was a
train who leaked all the stormfront nazi
stuff to the press a-train sees how
homelander has sided with the deep after
everything that i've done for that man i
know i'm [__] garbage so if he's
gonna get back in homelanders good books
he'll have to give him something better
than a refreshing turbo rush this is why
he turns in super sonic who revealed to
a train starlight's plan to take
homelander down back in russia mother's
milk chastises butcher on being a sorry
did you
just call god a c word and it's here we
learn why butcher chose mother's milk
because of his ability to keep everyone
together because no matter how wide i
gotta be
your ear
to look after the boys this is basically
a setup for the end of the episode where
mother's milk tells butcher the boys are
over there's a lot of cool stuff here in
the dildo attack scene most of which i
can't show or else i'll get demonetized
and a lot of this centers around kimiko
first we'll see her trip on her heels
this is a woman who has rarely if ever
worn heels she ends up scaring the [__]
of these sex-trafficked women one of
them shooting her in the head she looks
at the blood on her body this is the
monster she has become it's not lost on
her the irony that she too was once a
slave back in the u.s victoria newman
gives a press conference which was
supposed to admonish homelander but in a
twist ends up revealing an investigation
into her father pertaining to blackmail
perjury and obstruction of justice this
is all part of a plan between homelander
and victoria an uneasy alliance if you
will homelander revealed to victoria her
true past and that to stan she wasn't
his daughter but his weapon in exchange
for bringing down stan edgar the only
man who really kept homelanders powers
in check homelander would give victoria
a dose of original compound v a dose she
will later give to her daughter by
giving her this compound v victoria
believes she'll be protecting her
daughter i'm really excited to see how
this manifests in zoe because damn the
bone cracks and noises when she took it
did not sound pleasant this is also one
of a few times throughout the entire
series that homelander brings up this
idea of supes versus humans whereas
x-men has this as one of its biggest
themes the boys tends to veer away from
it however not in this scene and with
homelanders saying a few episodes ago
he'd gladly destroy the world and stan
edgar telling him the people will
eventually turn on him i could see this
supes versus humans thread turning into
a much larger plot point especially
considering there may be a way to
reverse one's suit powers as seen with
kimiko cameron coleman is brought into
ashley and essentially told he'll be
getting his talking points from her and
damn is it just me or is ashley really
getting kinky this season kimiko brings
proof of her assassination of the
oligarch and the team can finally prep
for their infiltration of the russian
base which apparently has this super
weapon it's here butcher shoots up some
temp v but is caught by huey huey wants
to try it too but butcher says he's not
power
he's punishment we've already seen how
butcher's taking of temp v has affected
his relationships especially ryan's
which is ironic because he's taking it
for ryan sooner or later
homeland that will find ryan stan
doesn't know what homelander gave
victoria in order to have her turn on
him he seems kind of at peace with the
fact his daughter outplayed him even
though homelander may have won this
battle stance's homelander has lost the
one thing that protected him vot has
always been there to clean up his mess
take for example in diabolical where he
accidentally killed a bunch of hostages
but vaught made it look like he was a
hero with no one there to cover up for
him the people will see him for the
disappointment he is you are not a god
you are simply
bad product are you familiar
with my product infiltrating the
compound the boys uncover this almost
cryo-chamber-like device but notice here
there are two instances of both mother's
milk and kimiko packing away documents
like they didn't need this shot here if
this wasn't going to be important going
forward maybe these documents hold some
insight into the experiments going on
here and what went down with soldier boy
expect these to make an appearance next
episode of course there's that adorable
hamster jamie and a reference to rocky
iv i must thank you it's here butcher
butchers the baddies say that 10 times
fast and huey reveals more than just his
powers we only get a quick glimpse of
what these entail at first i thought
this might be some sort of invisibility
mixed with super speed but i think it's
more of a teleportation kind of thing
one which his body dematerializes and
re-materializes hence his clothes coming
off he also has healing powers as
evidenced when he takes off his cast
everyone isn't too happy with huey's
decision to take tem v but it arguably
saved mother's milk's life just how this
will change huey going forward will be
interesting to see will he crave the
power and will it become a punishment
like butcher feared on to soldier boy
who seems to be constrained and sedated
in this machine i wonder if he's really
been in there for almost 40 years in his
escape he lets out this huge energy
blast at power which butcher said
soldier boy never had they must have
done something to him it's entirely
possible the russians were looking for
ways to take away a soup's power supes
who could sway the outcome of wars a
weapon like this could even the playing
field against the americans our final
sequence involves homelander and
starlight playing it up for the cameras
homelander flies starlight to reveal the
mutilated corpse of super sonic it's a
dire warning for starlight if she
continues plotting against him this is
what will happen to huey and while
episode 3 ended with starlight clenching
her fist in anger episode 4 ends in
despair her plans seemingly undone but
the big wild card in all of this is
soldier boy from the trailers he doesn't
look like he's much of a good guy and at
the same time i've theorized that
homelander may garner support from his
fans to bring down soldier boy who has
gone rogue in this image here we can see
a down soldier boy statue as homelander
speaks to a group of adoring fans but
what do you think i love reading your
thoughts and theories in the comments
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe i'll be covering
every episode of the season and if you
haven't taken a look the link to my
episode 123 video is in the description
until next time remember